hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're focusing on an
introduction to viruses viruses caused a
number of important payment diseases for
example measles mumps HIV polio
influenza SARS hepatitis these are all
important human diseases so this is why
we study viruses before we get into
talking about what a virus looks like
what its structure is like let me ask
you a question our virus is alive seems
like a pretty straightforward question
right but I think it's actually fairly
complicated and it's not something that
people give a lot of thought to in order
to decide whether or not a virus is
alive let's look at the definition of a
virus we know that viruses are a small
non cellular infectious particle that
contains both protein and nucleic acid
that cannot reproduce by itself let me
draw your attention to two factors first
viruses are non cellular and they cannot
reproduce by themselves meaning they
can't reproduce outside of a host now
usually when we think of something
that's being alive it's at least made up
of one cell if not many cells also in
order for life to happen you have to be
able to reproduce right so both of these
things would suggest that no viruses are
not alive more evidence to this fact
includes the case that viruses do not
have ribosomes these are the organelles
that synthesize proteins so viruses are
not capable of protein production also
viruses cannot make energy they're not
capable of normal cellular metabolism so
they can't generate ATP so most people
the general thought is that no viruses
are not alive they're just very complex
sort of machines you can think of them
in that way however some people point
out truthfully that viruses do have
numerous capabilities that is required
for life for example they respond to
their environment they cause disease
they are capable of replication
and once they're in a host cell and they
are also able to evolve for example this
is why we need a flu shot every year
because the flu virus changes so much
over time that we need to keep being
immunized against it so when asking is a
virus alive most of the time the answer
is no but depending on your textbook and
your teacher sometimes the question is
we're not really sure it's a little bit
of a gray area okay so now let's talk
about virus structure all viruses have
two main components these are a nucleic
acid core this would be the genome and
this nucleic acid core is surrounded by
a protein coat that is called the capsid
the capsid is what protects the nucleic
acid core from the environment the
capsid is also important for allowing a
virus to enter into a host cell and then
be transmitted out of a host cell again
the nucleic acid core is where we find a
lot of the diversity between different
types of viruses nucleic acid core can
be made of double-stranded DNA double
stranded RNA single-stranded DNA or
single-stranded RNA and there are
different replication mechanisms for
these different types of viruses also
that nucleic acid core can be circular
or it can be linear it can even be
segmented which means more than one
linear piece of nucleic acid now to also
indicate the range of diversity among
viruses let's talk about how many
nucleotides are common in a viral genome
nucleotides of course are the building
blocks that make up DNA and RNA the
smallest viral genomes
are about 3000 nucleotides the largest
viral genomes are about 250,000
nucleotides so you can see that there's
quite a range here where the viruses
that have more nucleotides they have
more kinetic information they are
generally more complex now just to put
this in perspective though how many
nucleotides do you think are in the
human genome for example humans is about
3.2 billion nucleotides so you can see
that while there is certainly a range
here for viruses all the viruses are far
less complex than an organism like a
human being now also some viruses have
an additional component called an
envelope the envelope is made of lipids
carbohydrates and proteins and the
envelope is important because it can
actually help to mask the virus from the
immune system this is because viruses
that are enveloped take this envelope
from the host cell membrane when they
exit the host cell so that when the
immune system sees this envelope it
actually thinks that it's just seeing a
host cell so this is one of the ways
that viruses can evade the immune system
now if we look at virus shapes there is
a fairly large diversity here for
example with bacterial ages these are
viruses that infect bacteria cells we
have this captain structure the nucleic
acid and there's also a component where
the bacteria phage uses these things
that kind of look like little legs to
attach to the bacterial cell and then
inject the DNA so this is what a
bacterial page looks like
if you'd like more information on how
the bacteriophage works you can see my
video on transaction there is also
tobacco mosaic virus tobacco mosaic
virus is quite small and it is elongated
of course this is the virus that infects
the plant the tobacco plant another
example of a shape that a virus can take
is poliovirus poliovirus is quite small
it's still got that capsid shape with a
nucleic acid core but it's much smaller
than some of these other viruses another
example of a different shape that a
virus can take is Ebola virus Ebola
virus sort of forms this long loop like
structure of the capsid with the nucleic
acid inside it also important to think
about is the size of these viruses now
viruses are typically 20 to 100
nanometers in size this is quite small
when you think that the average
bacterial cell is upwards of a thousand
nanometers and the average animal cell
at human cells are upwards of 10,000
nanometers so you can see how small
these structures are compared to the
host cells that they are infecting okay
now let's talk about viral replication
viral replication is extremely complex
this is because there are so many
different types of viruses that
replicate through different mechanisms
for example with bacteria ages those
viruses that infect bacterial cells they
actually just attach to the bacterial
cell inject the nucleic acid into the
cell all the viral capsid
on the outside on the other hand animal
viruses they actually enter the animal
cell captive at all there are also
numerous different mechanisms for the
different types of nucleic acid core
this means that RNA viruses and DNA
viruses have different mechanisms some
RNA viruses are able to copy their RNA
directly into proteins others have to
transcribe a complementary strand before
that can happen
you also have retroviruses that take
their RNA genome reverse translated into
DNA which then gets integrated with the
host genome and copy that way on the
other hand DNA viruses have to use post
cellular machinery to copy their DNA so
you can see that this can become very
complicated for today we're just going
to use the example of an animal cell
virus so a virus and infect animal cells
that has a DNA core let's start over
here in black we have the cell here we
have the red nucleic acid core blue
capsid and the green envelope note that
the virus envelope attaches to the cell
plasma membrane via a receptor mediated
fashion this step is called attachment
once attachment occurs you have the
second step which is endocytosis
note that the attachment relied on
specific receptors this is what gives
the virus what's called host restriction
it's only able to infect cells of a
specific host based on the receptors
that are present then the end of
psychosis occurs note that once the
virus enters the cell was actually
happened here the green envelope of the
virus he uses with the cell membrane you
can see here that we had what was once
the soft membrane used with what was
once the viral envelope this means that
what actually comes inside the cell
is just the capsid surrounded by or
excuse me the capsid surrounding the
nucleic acid core the next step is
uncoding encoding is when host cell
proteins are used to actually break down
the capsid resulting in a nucleic acid
core than being available for
replication now following this uncoding
process various things have to happen
first the DNA is replicated this happens
in the nucleus why does it happen in the
nucleus you might ask why is that
important well remember that viruses are
obligate intracellular parasites they
are only capable of replicating inside a
host cell the reason for this is that
they must use host cell machinery in
order to replicate because they don't
have all of the proteins and nucleotides
and amino acids that they need in order
to form new virus particles now where is
the host cell machinery for DNA
replication well in the nucleus because
that's
host cells DNA now you had an RNA genome
in a virus it could actually be
replicated in the cytoplasm because it
doesn't need that DNA replication
machinery quality na is being replicated
you also have capsid proteins female
this happens in the cytoplasm why do you
think that it well think about where
proteins are made they're made by
ribosomes which are organelles that are
present in the cytoplasm the fact that
protein synthesis is happening in the
cytoplasm and makes sense once you have
the DNA replicated and the capsid
proteins produced the next step is viral
assembly this is just when the
replicated DNA genomes are packaged
inside the capsid to form a structure
like this the final step is called
membrane fusion
remember infusion and release is how the
new virus particles acquire an envelope
they basically move to the outside of
the cell and they fuse with the post
cell membrane and then they exit the
cell and are released this means that
the envelope that is covering each new
virus particles is actually taken
directly from the host cell and as you
discussed before this is an important
mechanism that viruses use to evade the
immune system these when immune system
cells sense that viral envelope but
they're actually recognizing is post
cell components and thus the virus can't
travel to a new host cell to continue
its infection cycle without being
stopped by the immune system so that is
the basics of viral replication that's
all I've got for today so I hope you
learned a lot and thank you for watching
biology professor